la fibromialgia es una enfermedad
Crónica o de larga duración provoca
dolores musculares y articulares en todo
el cuerpo la causa exacta de la
fibromialgia es desconocida Pero puede
tratarse de un problema en la forma en
que los nervios y el cerebro perciben
las señales de dolor las personas con
fibromialgia son mucho más sensibles a
las experiencias sensoriales como la
presión el calor o el frío las luces
brillantes y el ruido en comparación con
las personas sin fibromialgia algunos
motivos que pueden aumentar el riesgo de
padecerlas son antecedentes familiares
de fibromialgia traumatismos físicos o
traumas emocionales y estrés tener
ciertas enfermedades como la artritis
reumatoide o el lupus tener ansiedad y
depresión ser mujer y ser de mediana
edad o mayor
los síntomas más comunes de la
fibromialgia incluyen dolor y
sensibilidad en el cuerpo sentir mucho
cansancio problemas para dormir
problemas cognitivos y de memoria
conocidos Como fibroniebla o
fibroneblina y dolores de cabeza otros
síntomas pueden incluir hormigueo o
entumecimiento de las manos y los pies
problemas de Salud Mental como ansiedad
o depresión y problemas digestivos como
el síndrome del intestino irritable o la
enfermedad por reflujo gastroesofágico
dado que la fibromialgia no tiene cura
el tratamiento se centra en aliviar sus
síntomas los tratamientos pueden incluir
medicamentos cambios en el estilo de
vida y psicoterapia o terapia
conversacional los medicamentos que su
proveedor de atención médica puede
prescribir para ayudar a reducir el
dolor y mejorar el sueño incluyen
antidepresivos y anticonvulsivos
también se le puede aconsejar que tomen
analgésicos antiinflamatorios de venta
libre sin embargo la fibromialgia no
causa inflamación por lo que no suelen
ser útiles para el dolor de la
fibromialgia
algunos cambios en el estilo de vida
pueden ayudar a controlar los síntomas
de la fibromialgia entre estos se
encuentran dormir lo suficiente hacer
ejercicio con regularidad y mantenerse
activo
y tener una alimentación saludable el
objetivo de la terapia conversacional es
ayudarle a cambiar su forma de pensar o
actuar
puede ayudarle a aprender formas de
afrontar los síntomas y proporcionarle
apoyo
para conocer más sobre la fibromialgia
habla con su proveedor de atención
médica